welcome to the CDO playing the repo men
GM repo man so you have a name nope only
fun fake name ok the Banco let's see
what he does against Knight f3 there
should be seven enough do you do against
that hmm I have forgotten friend I
really must admit I have forgotten 92
was a move that I had studied a while
ago
maybe do that e six you for but I really
have forgotten how it is continued okay
you can also take then e 46
hmm interesting this I've never seen
before I don't know yeah it looks a bit
tricky now how do i develop you for
playing in gambit style it could be
interesting takes Bishop d3 it's a very
quick development maybe try that 92
Bishop t2 is really quick developing
them so probably he will play 926 then
castles rookie one now if he takes now
94 as a as a nice tempo so what about
this position do I have any sort of
compensation I can take and take on b5
yeah that looks good actually because I
free the c-4 square for night see form
and he cannot easily play cannot easily
play d5 p.m. so i should be big cookie
oh ok night c4 let's see for quincy
seven it's no direct way to refute this
i'd like to get an Bishop a form now
after night see for Quincy seven okay
let's do that it's not clear that i have
anything better in any case
I wonder Bishop d2 intending Bishop f5
this is a move but you can always go to
to have form ok I'm going to play for
quick development here Andy if either
always have 95 so this is not not a
problem it's not so clear how we
developed anyway moving the deep on
always we can see six considerably yeah
something like that and maybe 90 for the
second tribe I can take now maybe on
I'll play rookie won the rookie won it
might take only five let's let's take
and get the Queen to 27 right you four
is always this counter play but I at the
moment I can take it and so maybe
threaten on age seven
God Bishop b5 still still in the mix
that looks looks quite okay I'm
certainly but take your first not sure
about the move order here and on 95
ideal would be night c 4 33 maybe you
can play III III could be the most 96
Queen gphi of something something like
that no okay I don't I don't think I can
be any worse see if I go if I get to 22
mp3 this is blocking his bishop and he's
got some weaknesses c5 is the most
serious one and also I've got these two
points against I can take you better not
yeah I don't I didn't want to allow em
coming to 2d too so what to hear you can
go to deform maybe should I take maybe
maybe keep it simple and take a look
before but I can play against c5 I have
do you want covered so the only problem
here is the time with a little bit more
time on the clock I would be rather
confident about winning this looks very
good especially the bishop Iran be
sadness is really bad yeah it's not
tricky though he's got to always has
some some ideas maybe
time morning yeah I still won't want to
take I don't don't see a particularly
dangerous trick here here it is look see
eight what a stupid move I mean jive of
course not no tears okay
it's difficult to to coordinate distance
pieces ah c8 how silly is that yeah this
game was a was very one-sided but I hope
we looked simply rook c8 those first
games in a session are always to give me
my pawns are vulnerable this is the the
main problem him a for especially
check and I can give the check on me
five oh what a silly game I didn't do
that even would it have been just just
wrong
my peace coordination is is questionable
again you can give us a check on e5 so I
don't know however how exactly is going
to win this line can maybe get get the
queenside pawns somehow
check yes I don't I don't see it really
wins maybe with some porn advances and
one time may of course
check check white boy hey that's that
simply the case of this this completely
anachronistic time controls can always
play and play on time even if you have
no winning idea whatsoever hear ya black
has already already substantially worse
I can just take and take onee form and
at the end he just blundered the Queen
yeah I have overlooked Roxy eight and
this is my my main problem he got towed
totally outplayed here I mean this is
just winning for white I only have to
avoid Crete c5 even this is good for
what I apologize this as a win as well
but with rook c7 now because I get a
seven hmm yeah I'm down I'm down on time
iam yeah this was just just very bad bad
game by black now hear your 95 is even
is even winning more clearly but ok this
is this is leading to a to a technically
almost winning position with the night
only three he has them the dead bishop
him the dead bishop on on b7 and I just
I just must avoid to take I mean even if
this is good for white I should still um
just play and play some strengthening
moves that he has no no play whatsoever
I can play age 30 or something that is
just helping the abbot and where are we
here it is not I have some problems here
with the bond I don't know why
whoopsie one it does not move the pieces
I don't know why I shouldn't take on c5
it just makes the thing too complicated
it does not put it on the board this is
really weird yeah I shouldn't take on c5
we'll just make things more complicated
the queen is always easier to play with
with limited time then rook and enter
piece because you always have to
coordinate which is which is tricky ok
thanks for watching